it's exciting times it's finding all the
major press outlets BBC New York Times
cosmologies front page it's a really
good they've been looking out into the
sky looking at the microwave background
there's a radiation from the Big Bang
and finding small fluctuations in the
temperature of this radiation and
they've done it to an unprecedented
accuracy so by looking at the sky today
you're constraining some of the earliest
phenomena in the universe is that
literally what they're doing either
they're going the temperature there is
that the temperature there is that the
temperature there is that is it that
simple it's pretty much that what
they're looking at temperature
differences but there means they are
looking at the temperatures in different
parts of the sky and comparing them and
by doing that you can your theories
actually predict what those temperatures
should be like and so by looking at this
distribution of these temperatures you
actually begin to constrain your
theories different theories will have a
different distribution of the
temperatures what sort of temperatures
are we looking at here very very cold
very very cold the background
temperature of the of this radiation and
is about 2.7 degrees Kelvin this is two
point seven degrees above absolute zero
but that's not what the real excitement
is that has been known for a long time
the excitement is that this background
temperature which is amazingly uniform
it looks the same within whichever
direction you look in the sky there are
actually small fluctuations in it how
can I even do this space is full of
galaxies and stars and black holes
burning hydrogen and all sorts how can
you point your thermometer yeah anywhere
and get a measure something that cold
that's crucial but you've hit the nail
on the head and this is why it takes so
long to do it of course the temperature
that we see is way higher than that
there's radiation coming from all sorts
of sources even locally right from the
Sun there's masses of radiation that
keep us alive and you have to manage
somehow to subtract all of that so the
first thing that they do is this
satellite the Planck satellite this send
up into a particular orbit
it's points always pointing away from
the Sun but you've still got the fact
that we're part of a galaxy and the
galaxy is full of dust and radiation of
all different wavelengths lots and lots
of stars shining and so they have to
actually subtract all of these all of
these sources the the thing that's in
their favor that allows them to do it is
that different sources whether it be
dust in the universe or x-rays or
infrared they all come with different
wavelengths and so if they have enough
detectors sensitive to those wavelengths
then they can actually see how much is
coming in each wavelength and that's
what Planck has you can extract all that
out and with a bit of luck what you're
left with is the primordial Cosmic
Microwave Background that was emitted
about 380,000 years after the Big Bang
the early universe was very hot and
dense and it was full of particles and
full of radiation and that radiation was
was very hot very high-energy particles
very high-energy radiation it was too
hot for particles to combine and form
atoms say because as soon as they try
and combine as soon as an electron would
try and orbit around a proton and that's
where we got our hydrogen a photon of
light would come in and smash it apart
because it was too high energy but the
universe is expanding and we know that
if if you've got radiation in a box
that's expanding the radiation cools
down its wavelength begins to stretch so
eventually there will have been an epoch
when when the electrons began to form to
go around the protons most of the
photons of light didn't have enough
energy to break them up again that and
that moment is when the atom first
hydrogen atoms formed that's Wendy and
that's when the radiation decoupled from
the particles and that is the formation
of the Cosmic Microwave Background it
happened about 380,000 years after the
Big Bang
just before then right just before this
decoupling when the photons are released
what you actually what you you have of
these particles that you have the you
have your fundamental particles right we
believe we had quarks and we have
electrons and we have neutrinos all part
of the standard model of fundamental
particles
and in the early universe when it's so
hot they haven't been able to combine
their there they're moving around freely
and so you have what's known as a plasma
a plasma of these particles and you've
got the you've got radiation photons
shooting around but because these
particles are free there are many many
of them a high density of them so
imagine now a photon I'll be a photon
here I come in and I hit a particle I
bounced off the particle but now I hit
another one and I bounce off that and I
hit another one and hardly go anywhere
so it's called a very have a very short
mean free path between the collisions
this means that the universe when I'm
looking back at it looks opaque I can't
see into it because the photons haven't
been able to get to me now as the
universe cools down a number of things
happen after about three minutes
the first nuclei begin to form the the
quarks manage to combine to give me
protons and neutrons and they begin to
combine to give me the early the early
nucleus of the lightest elements then if
I wait 300,000 880 380,000 years or so
the temperature has dropped down enough
that the of the photons that the
electrons which up until now have been
flying around as well and the same thing
has been happening the foot the photons
are banging off these electrons and
hardly going anywhere these electrons
begin to form atoms you know the
combined with the protons and form your
hydrogen all of a sudden the density of
the particles has dropped because
they've all they're combining to give me
these atoms and now I have big gaps
basically between the particles so your
typical photon just shoots straight
through now and that's when I I can then
see it how they interact after that when
it when it left when when it left those
atoms and left them alone and wave them
goodbye that that temperature is about
3,000 degrees Kelvin and but as the
universe is expanded that it's cooled
down that that red isn't cooled down
basically it gets stretched and it just
calls it fills this bigger and bigger
volume until today it's about three
degrees Kelvin so it is a remnant of the
of the of that earliest moments and it's
just been cooling ever since the
microwave background red
which has been propagating since the
atoms formed is incredibly smooth in
this it's got the same temperature in
all directions and that was determined
whether the microbe backgrounds were
first discovered in the 1960s by Penzias
and Wilson and the the smoothness of it
was really demonstrated in 1992 by the
Coby satellite that on top of this
beautifully smooth background as some
very small fluctuations these pop we
know one part a few parts in a hundred
thousand so temperatures of 2.73 degrees
Kelvin plus or minus 10 to the minus 5
degrees Kelvin a bit hotter here or a
bit colder there but very small
deviations it's vital that those
deviations are there without that
deviate those deviations in the
temperature actually we wouldn't be here
it's that dramatic if the universe was
perfectly smooth structures in the
universe would never form and and one of
the things we're trying to understand is
a what what do these deviations really
look like what's their distribution on
the sky and then from a theory
standpoint how did the come that you say
without the deed without these
deviations hmm
structures wouldn't exist yeah but the
deviations were caused by the formation
of atoms no no it's not you can make the
deviations were there where before that
the way way before that these deviations
in fact these lead this is what makes
this so cool is that those deviations or
their origin if it's if the theories are
correct to the inflationary universe and
in the inflationary universe that
occurred there that period of inflation
where the universe expanded
exponentially rapidly that occurred
about within the first 10 to the minus
30 seconds after the Big Bang and the
flood shoot and that that expansion
actually had associated with its small
quantum fluctuations in the field that
was responsible for the expansion which
is called the in photon field small
fluctuations in this field and it's that
that we now see in the microwave
background we see the effect of those
small fluctuations so they were they
were imprinted in the
in our gravitational field much earlier
than than when the atoms were formed so
what you're looking at if if the
theories are correct what you're looking
at is actually evidence of the slightly
different movements of the of this in
photon field it's called of the thing
that drives that early period of
acceleration different parts of the
universe were driven at different rates
because the in photon had had different
values in different parts of the
universe this field had a different
value in different parts of the universe
and because of the fluctuations in it
due to quantum mechanics then those
fluctuations imprint themselves
eventually through to the Microwave
Background fluctuations basically what
happens is those fluctuations in the
field couple through to the
gravitational field and the
gravitational field is the thing that
then determines how through Einstein's
equations tells us how matter and
radiation move and and so by seeing how
the radiation moves that's seen how hot
and cold that radiation is we can see
something about those initial
fluctuations in this field the reason
why you need some fluctuation is pretty
straightforward I think imagine there
was no fluctuation imagine you are an
atom in the very early universe and
everything is perfectly smooth
everywhere you around look around you it
looks exactly the same I have to form
structures somehow as if I'm an atom
it's going to be part of a structure I
have to determine where am i God where
am I going to go now the universe is
just as smooth here as it is here as it
is in front of me as it is behind me I
have no preferred direction to going and
so I've basically stay still and now
that my neighboring atom feels exactly
the same and the one beside it and the
one beside it there is no way that
there's no preferred direction for
structures to begin to form
however if if instead of that you have
it's almost smooth but you have small
ripples and in the matter content maybe
a bit more here in a little bit less
here in a bit more here then an atom
that's here will move preferentially
that way and
of this region behind does this mean
that the world's greatest cosmologists
armed with all the equations they want
could look at this wobble in the in
photon field and accurately predict what
the universe was going to look like in
13.8 billion years no see the simplest
on field actually eventually decays and
it has to reach as it decay as it
releases its energy and it has to
produce all the particles and radiation
that we see today so the only way that
we can really predict what that's going
to look like is by knowing how the
Implanon field is coupled to these
particles so just in its own the in some
field isn't enough to give me that
information I guess what I'm asking is
are we inevitable predetermined
projection of what happened all that
time ago or did more or more dice roll
in between now on it
we're not predetermined in the sense
that the distribution of these even the
distribution of these hot and cold spots
on the microwave background that's a
statistical distribution some of those
led to structures forming others didn't
and and and that's it's that's a chance
thing as to you know what where the hot
and cold spots really appeared that then
lead led to structures so the news is
that the planck collaboration which is a
big big collaboration you involving a
number of countries and scientists from
a number of countries have measured this
microwave background to incredible
accuracy and they put out their data
showing you what the map looks like of
the of the Microwave Background
fluctuations showing you you know where
the power is in this map compared you're
looking at different scales on the
universe with what different scales
contribute to the overall map and and
then comparing the map with the the
favorite models of our universe and the
the the initial impression seems to be
that the standard model of cosmology
that people have which is basically a
universe made up of baryons that's what
you and i are made of of dark matter and
then dark energy in the form of a
cosmological constant
subject to these initial period of
inflation and the fluctuations that that
infla tom field provided that that seems
to fit the data beautifully incredibly
well and so the they call it the vanilla
model of the universe seems to be
working well although as they point out
there are because they've now got sort
of incredible sensitivity on small
angular scales and on large angular
scales they've actually begin to see the
odd thing that sort of not fitting the
standard model very well it was it was
actually pointed out previously by
another fantastic experiment called W
map which was the previous generation to
this Planck one and they'd seen the odd
little anomaly that didn't seem to fit
the standard model but I think overall
the standard model is looking pretty
healthy the map is a map of the hot and
cold spots in the universe and all
different scales and what you look for
are correlations you look for how one
bit of the of the sky correlates with
another bit of the sky and by doing that
you can work out what's known as the
power spectrum you can work out the
power on any given scale in the universe
how how much is that on that given scale
that given angular scale how much is it
contributing to them these fluctuations
and you end up with a series of
beautiful peaks and troughs you know
because things peak at one particular
scale and then there's not much at
another scale and this is all to do with
theory tells us that it should be
looking like this it's the effect of
baryons and photons acting together in
the early universe your models actually
tell you what that peak and trough
distribution should look like for any
given model with any given distribution
of matter and dark matter and dark
energy you can work out what you expect
this peak and troughs to look like both
where they are and how high they are
relative to one another
and so what you'd basically do with this
wonderful data is you you look what the
distribution looks like and then you
begin to test it against the different
models to see which fit the data best
and which don't and through it you
actually begin to rule out classes of
models and
other classes look to be fitting the
data better than other things do you
actually look at what's in space do you
look at the map and go there's a warm
patch there's a cold patch and wherever
there's a warm patch it seems there are
more galaxies people do do that yes that
generally you're looking at the
statistics you're looking at the
statistical distribution service what of
these hot and cold spots you know what's
the what's the typical number density of
spots of a given size of a given
temperature so that's that's a
statistical thing where you're not
particularly saying where they are but
of course you do like to know where they
are and one of the anomalies that seems
to be there which is a bit unusual is
that if I imagine that this the
observable sky and sort of separate it
into a Northern Hemisphere in a southern
hemisphere there seems to be a slight
excess temperature in the southern
hemisphere compared to the northern
hemisphere well given what I said
earlier about this isotropy and how you
expect it all to be uniform temperature
with these small fluctuations you don't
necessarily expect there to be this kind
of preponderance for hot a bit down here
and cold a bit up there and this is one
of the anomalies that people are trying
to understand is it is it telling me
something about new physics of the very
early universe or is it a systemic in
the way that the data has been collected
and then there are indeed some some
actual spots there's one in particular
that they've been highlighting which the
W map team also spotted so to speak
which is seems to be much colder and
it's a much colder spot in a bigger
region than you would normally expect
given the models that I'm telling you
about the the one that's got the
cosmological constants and the cold out
matter and the matter you wouldn't
naturally have expected such a big spot
but it's not out of the question it
could have formed it just seems to be
unusual